back here in southern nevada calico
basin it is one of the most popular
spots for hikers and bikers and the blm
says that is exactly why there needs to
be a gate and a fee to keep it all clean
it's a controversial proposal however
bianca coleman joining us live to
explain how you can weigh in on this
possible change bianca hey good morning
so we all know we have many hiking
trails around southern nevada and the
calico basin it's free it's a free
alternative that lots of people go to
but soon it could cost you to visit so
there have been virtual meetings over
the past weeks and today is the last day
to share your thoughts about the
proposed changes by the bureau of land
management so here are some of the
potential plans they want to add a gate
they want to add a fee and they also
want to eliminate mountain biking save
red rock group they understand the need
to preserve the area and keep it clean
but they want the blm to consider
everyone's thoughts and concerns
especially when it comes to closing
trails at 6 pm and biking
moving at all is good um definitely we
need more management there it would
definitely be good to see more rangers
there and they've hired more rangers in
the past and um if we can just keep
organization communication
open
then i think we can we can all work
together to protect the resource that we
all love i mean this is our public land
and if the public can help we we want to
protect it too
so you can still submit your comments on
the blm website all comments must be
submitted by 4 30 this afternoon bianca
holman live local now